monday marks the end of the
administration's 15 days slow the spread
initiative President Trump has said he
will then make a decision about how he
wants to move the country forward Paula
Reid is at the White House with more on
this story good morning Paula where does
the president currently stand on this a
good morning Gail the president still
appears to want to send at least some
Americans back to work but in order to
do that he needs help from state and
local leaders who do not appear to be
fully on board
especially now that the u.s. leads the
world in the number of confirmed cases
of coronavirus we have to go back this
is the United States of America on
Thursday President Trump deflected blame
for a historic surge in unemployment
well it's nobody's fault certainly not
in this country and revealed new details
about how he plans to encourage state
and local leaders to reopen businesses
in a letter to state governors he said
the White House plans to categorize
every county in America as high medium
or low risk we may take large sections
of our country that aren't so seriously
affected and we may do it that way but
we've got to start the process pretty
soon but one of his top coronavirus
experts dr. deborah birx says counties
should not resume normal life until
there is more data from expanded testing
this will be critical for our future as
we work together to really understand
where the virus is and where it is an in
real time as an increasing number of
states issue shelter in place or stay at
home orders the president's push to
loosen restrictions was met with some
resistance I'm concerned about the
desire of the President to ignore
potentially the science CBS News has
learned that Washington governor jay
Inslee whose state has been especially
hard hit by the outbreak had a
contentious exchange with President
Trump on a conference call with other
governors Thursday after the president
told the governor's the federal
government was a backup for them Inslee
told him we don't need a backup
we need a Tom Brady the president also
criticized Michigan's governor Gretchen
Whitmer referred to her as the woman
governor and saying that she failed to
step up in her response to the virus
she shot back on Twitter saying that she
has asked repeatedly and respectfully
for assistance and called for no more
political attacks Tony all right Paula
thank you very much